ici les entraîneurs et nous attendons
d'eux qu'ils soient des modèles
ne commettez aucun format
marvin cornes quitte l'université du
wisconsin et se retrouve dans un lycée
huppé pour piller personnellement
j'estime que tout ceci est une grosse
erreur mais je vais te voir la commauté
olivard est assistant coach martin corp
dennis avait des conseils un jour ses
filles dirigeront la planète en place
certaines s'y voit déjà tu m'as chewing
gum 6 et westbrook nous on n'est pas
trop ambiance marche ou crève
travail en tant qu'entraîneur et de vous
aider à vous améliorer
je vais vous réapprendre le basket-ball
méthode marvin qu'en plus petits les
pavés plus rapide
c'est vraiment nécessaire le sifflet
absolument
je me doutais que ça serait dur mais là
c'est un autre niveau on arrête tout le
basket et leur enverrons je crois pas
qu'il soit vraiment méchant
quand on a su que vous allez venir ici
ça m'a vraiment motivé j'étais super
enthousiaste
seule chose qui compte pour moi c'est le
basket
militaires et pense que je peux jouer à
l'université de californie ou à stanford
mais après vous avoir fait jouer je
pense réellement on peut accomplir de
belles choses ça ne fait que commencer
ça fait un super boulot langues on peut
le refaire
vous avez créé un lien avec ses filles
n'ont pu tuer
voulais juste vous dire merci pour votre
soutien
john fitzgerald kennedy qu il a dit nous
allons faire ça non pas parce que c'est
facile mais justement parce que c'est
difficile mais il parlait de la lune
et si vous faites de votre mieux
l'équipe aura le potentiel pour aller
très bien
[Musique]
maintenant on va gagner ce match
[Applaudissements]